Lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo,
es un montón de desigualdades muy sencillas
y realmente lo valioso de que haga esto,
yo creo, que será justamente
introducirte a la notación de las desigualdades,
así que, vamos a empezar con una.
Digamos por ejemplo,
que tengo la desigualdad "x"
-5, menor
que 35,
entonces,
lo que me está diciendo esta expresión
es que necesitamos encontrar
todos los posibles valores de "x"
todos los posibles valores
que sean números reales
que satisfacen,
que siempre que le restemos 5 a ese número
sea más chico que 35
y por ejemplo,
puedes pensar en el 0,
que si le restamos 5
pues nos da -5
y por supuesto que es menor que 35 ¿verdad?
o puedes pensar en
en -10 que si le restamos -5
tendremos -15
y es menor que 35
ó puedes pensar incluso en el 20,
que si le restamos 5 nos da 15
y también es menor que 35,
entonces,
puedes notar de estas observaciones,
que a diferencia de las ecuaciones que hemos visto hasta ahorita,
las desigualdades en realidad
tienen un montón de soluciones,
tienen muchísimas soluciones
¿verdad?
bueno,
a después veremos algunas ecuaciones
que no tienen una única solución,
si no pueden tener varias,
pero hasta ahorita donde las las hemos visto,
siempre tienen una única solución,
aquí las desigualdades no,
tienen muchísimas, muchísimas soluciones,
y la idea es
encontrar todo el conjunto solución,
a esta desigualdad,
es decir, todos los "x" que satisfacen esta propiedad.
Y una forma de hacerlo y que es de hecho muy parecido a lo que trabajamos con las ecuaciones
es quitar,
o...
digamos despejar la "x" de todo los demás,
por ejemplo,
aquí podremos trabajar
igual que en las ecuaciones,
que tal si sumamos
de ambos lados un 5
sumamos
5 de ambos lados
y esto realmente lo podemos hacer
porque pensemos,
que si dos números están desbalanceados,
es decir, que no son iguales,
pues al sumarles la misma cantidad,
seguirán estando desbalanceados
¿verdad?
Piénsalo justo
como en una balanza
que no está igual,
si le pones la misma cantidad
seguirán desiguales
¿verdad?
Entonces si nosotros sumamos
5 de ambos lados,
nos podemos fijar que este 5 con el -5 se anulan
y del lado izquierdo me queda solo "x"
y "x" tiene que ser menor que
35 más 5 que son 40
Entonces
este es mi conjunto solución
de esta desigualdad,
son aquellos números que sean más chicos que 40
y no pueden ser iguales,
es decir
todos los "x" menores que 40,
así que vamos a dibujar una línea real,
una línea real...
para ver cómo se ve la solución de esta desigualdad,
por ejemplo aquí
tendremos el 40,
quizás acá ande del 41,
quizás acá ande el 42,
acá andará el 39,
el 38... ¿qué sé yo?
y así nos seguimos
38... y así nos seguimos, hacia la izquierda
y a la derecha
entonces me está diciendo
que la solución está dada,
por todos los números
que sean más chicos que 40,
es decir si lo queremos graficar,
aquí tenemos el 40
y son todos estos
que están a su izquierda
Todos estos...
Ahora,
¿por qué circule el 40?
Yo debería rellenarlo
si el 40 fuera solución,
pero en realidad
estamos excluyendo el 40,
el 40 no es solución porque fíjense muy bien,
40 menos 5 son 35
y no es cierto que 35 sea más chico que 35,
es exactamente igual ¿verdad?
Entonces el 40 no es parte de nuestra solución
y por eso lo dejamos con una bolita abierta,
y de hecho cualquier número más chico que 40, tan cercano al 40 como quieras,
por ejemplo el 39.99999...
todos los 9 que quieras,
siempre va a estar
en el conjunto solución ¿verdad?
Vamos a hacer otro ejemplo.
Digamos que tengo la ecuación...
la desigualdad más bien,
vamos a hacerlo acá
"x" más 15,
es mayor o igual que -60,
entonces vamos a notar aquí
que ya cambiamos el signo de la desigualdad,
ahora estamos diciendo
que este número es más grande,
o puede ser también igual
que -60,
entonces,
vamos a proceder como lo hicimos en el...
en el ejercicio anterior,
vamos a sumar algo de ambos lados,
por ejemplo,
podemos sumar -15
y de hecho lo voy a poner digamos...
acá abajito,
entonces sumamos -15 de ambos lados,
¿qué me queda del lado izquierdo?
pues 15 menos 15 se anulan
y sólo me queda "x" ¿verdad?
solo me queda "x"...
y esto va a ser mayor o igual
que -60 menos 15 que eso son -75
Entonces,
¿Cómo se vería aquí la solución?
Tenemos ¡Ups!
Lo hice un poco chueco,
tenemos aquí
nuestra recta de números nuevamente...
Colocamos por aquí el -75,
digamos que este es -75
acá andará -76,
-74 va para acá,
-73,
y así sucesivamente,
¿verdad?
hacia adelante y hacia atrás
y entonces nos tomamos todos los "x" que sean más grandes o iguales que -75
entonces aquí nos podemos tomar también el -75
y se puede también ser igual a -75,
en el caso anterior no podía ser igual,
y después, nos tomamos
todos los que sean más grandes que ese,
todos estos, entonces,
así es como se ve mi conjunto solución,
¿qué fue lo que obtuvimos?
que si yo tenía esta expresión de desigualdad,
al sumarle -15 llegamos justo a la solución,
que queríamos obtener,
y la gran diferencia aquí es que rellenamos el -75...
y de hecho es,
lo ponemos así una bolita
este...
llenita,
porque sí es una solución,
"x" puede ser a lo mejor muy grande,
por ejemplo, puede ser 1 millón,
3 millones
745 mil
¿Qué sé yo?.
todos esos son soluciones...
vámonos con otro ejemplo,
digamos uno un poquito más sencillo,
digamos que tenemos
"x" menos 2 menor o igual que 1
y vamos a proceder,
exactamente de la misma forma,
por ejemplo, para cancelar este -2,
pues le sumamos 2 de ambos lados,
¿y qué es lo que obtenemos?
del lado izquierdo,
estos se cancelan y tenemos
"x" menor o igual que 1 más 2,
que es 3,
Y entonces esto ya se empieza a volver
algo muy sencillo de
de trabajar,
volvemos a hacer nuestra línea de números...
nuestra línea de números,
un poco chueca pero,
línea al final de cuentas,
por ejemplo aquí andará el 0,
el 1, el 2, el 3
quizás hasta ponemos el 4,
acá anda el -1, - 2, - 3
y me dice que la solución
o el conjunto solución de esto es,
todos los más chicos
o iguales que 3
entonces,
podemos tomarnos,
por ejemplo,
nos tomamos,
desde 3,
porque el 3 sí lo podemos incluir,
y nos vamos toda la izquierda
todos los más chicos
o iguales que 3
y esta es la solución,
lo puedes verificar tú mismo,
por ejemplo cuando "x" es 3,
tenemos 3 menos 2 que es 1,
y sí, sí cumple,
por ejemplo si "x" es 0,
tenemos 0 menos 2 es -2
que también es menor o igual que 1
y así puedes tomarte varios ejemplos.
Vamos a hacer un último de estos,
por ejemplo,
"x" menos 32
es menor o igual que 0,
entonces
¿Cómo quitamos el 32?
Pues sumamos 32 de ambos lados,
Sumamos 32
¿y qué es lo que obtenemos?
Que "x" estos se cancelan,
es menor o igual que 32,
entonces si pintamos aquí,
mi recta de números, nuevamente,
por ejemplo que aquí anda
el 32, el 31, el 30,
entonces nos tomamos,
todos los que son menores o iguales,
podemos incluir el 32
y todos los que están a la izquierda,
y así es como se de la solución,
y recordemos siempre rellenamos
cuando podemos incluir este número en la solución,
aquí no lo podíamos incluir ¿verdad?
no hay esta posibilidad
de que sea igual, por lo tanto en este ejemplo,
el 40 no era parte de la solución.